and King is with us Ian markets just
opening aren't they what's happening
yeah I've just been looking at the guilt
Market very very little action at the
open but it is very very early days
um as I said to you a half an hour ago
okay I mean fiscally speaking this
really doesn't move the needle in terms
of the policy announcements that were
made when uh quasi-karting unveiled his
fiscal package uh a week or so ago just
over a week ago this was a very very
small element in it it's only about two
billion pounds all in and in fact in the
next fiscal year it was actually going
to raise some 625 million pounds because
of the impact it would have had in terms
of the timing of payments of bonuses so
it's not a big measure in terms of the
public finances per se certainly not in
terms of the extra borrowing that the
chancellor was taking on so you have to
assume that the reaction is really down
to what it tells you about the
government and its willingness to stick
to its guns and stick to policies you
saw a reaction in the pound of course
the foreign exchange markets are 24-hour
a day Sterling initially Rose by as much
as two-thirds of one percent against the
US dollar it's given back most of those
gains over the last half to three
quarters an hour or so Sterling now up
to only by a tenth of one percent right
now against the US dollar I think uh
such reaction is Sir there will be will
be in the guilt Market as I say it's uh
it's just opened it hasn't really moved
a great deal at the uh opening that's uh
of course down to other factors as well
the fact that the bank of England uh
wheeled out uh its bazooka last week to
intervene in the guilt Market at the
longer end of maturities 20 30 year
guilds that was the uh the big move that
we saw last week and I think that has
then introduced an element of stability
into all of this so I think what uh
people will be looking at now is really
as I say what this tells you about the
government's willingness is
determination to stick to its guns this
was after all a flagship policy that was
aimed advertising to the outside world
the government's willingness to focus on
growth above all else to try and make
the UK a more competitive environment
for entrepreneurs the additional rate of
tax did mean that the UK had a higher
rate of tax than many of its
International peers so doing away with
it was an attempt to make the UK more
competitive more attractive to
International businesses and
entrepreneurs and they've now done away
with that so uh that will be uh
something that people will will focus on
a great deal I think over the next 24
hours